the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so so far we've learnt about
partial derivatives and how to use them
to find minima and Maxima of functions
of two variables of several variables
and now we can try to study more in
detail how functions of several
variables behave how to compute their
variations how to estimate the variation
in arbitrary directions and so for that
we're going to need some more tools
actually to study these things so map
tools to study functions and
so today's topic is going to be
different Falls and just to motivate
that let me remind you about you know
one trick that you probably know from
single variable calculus namely implicit
differentiation
so let's say that you have a function y
equals f of X then you would sometimes
write dy equals f prime of x times DX
and then maybe you would excuse me can
you please take a seat and you please
take a seat and you know sit down that
would be better thank you so you know so
we use implicit differentiation to
actually relate infinitesimal changes in
Y with infinite small changes in X and
one thing we can do with that for
example is actually figure out the rate
of change dy by DX but also the
reciprocal DX by dy and so for example
let's say that we have y equals inverse
sine of X then we can write x equals
sine of Y and from there we can actually
find out what is the derivative of this
function if we didn't know the answer
already
by writing DX equals cosine Y dy and so
that tells us that dy over DX is going
to be 1 over cosine Y and now cosine
relation to sine is basically 1 over
square root of 1 minus x squared and
that's how you find the formula for the
derivative of the inverse sine function
ok formula but probably you already knew
but that's one way to derive it so
so now we are going to use also these
kinds of notations dxdy and so on but
use them for functions of several
variables and of course we'll have to
learn what other holes of manipulation
and what we can do with them so so the
actual name of that is the total d
control as opposed to the partial
derivatives because well it's going to
be the total differential because it
includes all of various causes that can
change that can sorry all of the
contributions that can cause the value
of your function f to change so namely
let's say that you have a function f may
be of three variables X Y Z then you
will write DF equals F sub X DX plus F
sub y dy plus F sub Z DZ they are maybe
+ to remind you of the other notation
partial F partial X DX plus partial F
partial Y dy plus partial F over partial
Z DZ now what is this object what you
know what are the things on either side
of this equality well they're called
differentials and they are not numbers
they are not vectors are not matrices
they are a different kind of object so
it these things have our own rules of
manipulations and we have to learn what
we can do with them so how do we think
about them so first of all how do we not
think about them
okay so here's an important thing too
pitfall to avoid so important the F is
not the same thing as Delta F okay so
that thing is meant to be a number it's
going to be a number once you have a
small variation of X a small variation
of Y small dilation of Z these are
numbers Delta X Delta Y Delta Z are
actual numbers and this becomes a number
this guy actually is not a number you
cannot give it a particular value all
you can do with a differential is
express it in terms of other
differentials so in fact this DX dy and
DZ well they're mostly symbols out there
but if you want to think about them
they're the differentials of XY and Z so
in fact you can think of these
differentials as placeholders where you
will put other things so of course they
represent you know there's this idea of
changes in X Y Z and F but so one way
that one could explain it I don't really
like that is to say they represent
infinitesimal changes another way to say
it and I think that's probably closer to
the truth is that these things are
somehow placeholders to put values and
get a tangent approximation so for
example if I do replace these symbols by
Delta X Delta Y and Delta Z numbers then
I will actually get a numerical quantity
and that will be an approximation
formula for Delta F it will be the
linear approximation of a tangent plane
approximation
so what we can do well so let me start
first with maybe something even before
that so the first thing that it does is
it can encode how changes in XYZ affect
the value of f I would say that some
more that's the most general answer to
what is this formula what are these
differentials
it's a relation between X Y Z and F and
in particular so this is a placeholder
for small variations Delta X Delta Y
Delta Z to get an approximation formula
which is Delta F is approximately equal
to F sub X Delta X plus F Y Delta Y plus
F Z Delta Z so it's getting clamped but
I'm sure you know what's going here so
and observe how this one is actually
equal while that one is approximately
equal so they're really not the same
another thing that the notation suggests
we can do and they claim we can do is
divide everything by some variable that
everybody depends on so say for example
that XY and Z actually depend on some
parameter T then they will vary at a
certain rate DX DT dy DT DZ DT and what
the differential will tell us then is
the rate of change of F as a function of
T when you plug in these values of XYZ
you will get DF DT by dividing
everything by DT in here
okay so the first thing we can do is
divide by something like DT to get an
infinitesimal rate of change one instant
we just take a rate of change okay so
the F DT equals F sub X DX DT plus F sub
y dy DT plus F sub Z DZ DT and that
corresponds to the situation where X is
a function of T Y is a function of T and
Z is a function of T then that means you
can plug in these values into F to get
where the value of F will depend on T
and then you can find the rate of change
with T of a value of f so these are the
basic rules and this is known as a chain
rule it's one instance of a chain rule
which tells you when you have a function
that depends on something and that
something in turn depends on something
else how to find the rate of change of a
function on the new variable in terms of
the derivatives of a function and also
the dependence between the various
variables okay any questions so far
nope okay so a word of warning in
particular about you know what I said up
here it's kind of unfortunate but the
textbook actually has a serious mistake
on that I mean they do have a couple of
formulas where they makes a deal with a
delta and they would like you not to do
that please okay so I mean there's DS
and those deltas and basically they
don't live in the same world they don't
see each other
the textbook is lying to you
okay so let's see I mean here I made you
know so the first and the second claims
I don't really need to justify because
the first one is just you know stating
some general principle but I'm not
making a precise mathematical claim the
second one well I mean we know that
approximation formula already so I don't
need to justify it for you but on the
other hand this formula here I mean you
probably have a right to expect some you
know reason for why this works why is
this valid after all I first told you we
have these new mysterious objects and
then I'm telling you well we can do that
but you know I kind of pulled it out of
my hat I mean I don't have a hat but so
okay so why is this valid how can I get
to this so here's the first attempt at
justifying how to get there okay so
let's see well we said DF is f sub X DX
plus F sub y dy plus F sub Z DZ but we
know well if X is a function of T then
DX is X prime of T DT or DX DT DT as you
cover okay
dy is y prime of T DT DZ is Z prime of T
DT so if we plug this into that formula
we'll get that DF is f sub x times X
prime of T DT plus F sub y y prime of T
DT plus F sub Z Z prime of T DT and now
well if I have a relation between DF and
DT see I got DF equals something times
DT that means the rate of change of F
with respect to T should be that
coefficient so if I divide by DT then I
get the formula that's I get the chain
rule now
well now that kind of works but that
shouldn't be completely satisfactory
let's say that short for skeptic and you
don't believe in differentials yet then
you know it's maybe not very good that I
actually used this more of these
differential notations in deriving the
answer so that's actually not how it's
proved you know the way in which you
prove the chain rule is not this way
because we don't we shouldn't have too
much trust in differentials of just yet
I mean at the end of today's lecture
yes probably we should believe in them
but so far we should still be a little
bit you know reluctant to believe no
this kind of strange object telling us
we are things so here's a better way to
think about it so one thing that we have
passed in so far our approximation
formulas yes we should have trust in
them so we should believe that if we
change X a little bit if we change Y a
little bit
then we are actually going to get a
change in F that's approximately given
by these guys so now well this is true
for any changes in X Y Z but in
particular let's look at the changes
that we get if we just take these
formulas as functions of time and change
time a little bit by delta T okay so
we'll actually use the changes in XYZ in
a small time delta T and let's divide
everybody by delta T ok here I'm just
dividing numbers so I'm not actually
playing any tricks on you I mean we
don't really know what it means to
divide differentials but dividing
numbers is something we know and now if
I take delta T very small then this guy
tends to the differential so it tends to
the derivative DF DT remember the
definition of DF DT is the limit of this
ratio when the time interval delta T
tends to 0 so that means if I get you
know I choose smaller and smaller values
of delta T then these ratios of numbers
will actually tend to some value and
that value is the derivative so
similarly here Delta x over delta T when
delta T is very small will tend to the
derivative dx/dt
and similarly for the others so
Oh
okay so that means particular so if we
take the limit as delta T tends to 0 we
get DF DT on one side on the other side
we get f sub X DX DT plus F sub y dy DT
plus F sub Z DZ DT and the approximation
becomes better and better
remember when we write approximately
equal that means that it's not quite the
same but if we take smaller and smaller
variations then actually we'll end up
with values that are getting closer and
closer so when we take the limit as
delta T tends to 0 eventually we get an
equality I mean mathematicians have more
complicated worlds to justify the
statement but I will spare them for now
and you will see about them when you
take analysis if you go on in that
direction ok any questions so far
nope
okay so let's check maybe things in an
example let's say that we really don't
have any faith in these things and so
let's try to do it so let's say I give
you a function that's x squared y plus Z
and let's say that maybe X will be T y
will be e to the T and Z will be sine T
okay so what does the chain will say
well the chain rule tells us that dw/dt
is so we start with partial W partial X
well what is that
that's 2xy times so maybe I should point
out this is w sub x times dx/dt plus
well W sub y is x squared times dy DT
plus W sub Z that's going to be just 1
DZ DT okay and so now let's plug in the
actual values of these things so X is T
Y is e to the T so that will be 2t e to
the t DX DT is 1 plus x squared is T
squared dy DT is e to the T plus DZ DT
is cosine T okay so at the end of
calculation we get 2t e to the T plus G
square e to the T plus cosine T that's
what the chain rule tells us how else
could we find that well we could just
plug in values of x y&z X plus W as a
function of T and take its derivative
okay
let's do that just for verification it
should be exactly the same answer and in
fact in this case the two calculations
are roughly equal in complication but
say that your function of XYZ was much
more complicated than that
or maybe you actually didn't know if
we Lafayette you only knew it's partial
derivatives then you would need to use
the chain rule
so sometimes plugging in values is
easier but not always
so let's just check quickly so the other
method would be to substitute so W is a
function of T well so remember W was was
it x squared y plus Z so as a function
of T well X was T so we get T squared Y
is e to the T plus Z was sine T so DW DT
we know how to take the derivative using
single variable calculus well we should
know if we don't know when we should
take a look at 1801 again so by the
product hole that will be derivative of
T square is 2t times e to the T plus Z
squared times the derivative of e to the
T is e to the T plus cosine T and that's
the same answer as over there so I ended
up writing up you know maybe I wrote
slightly more here but actually the
amount of calculations when it was
pretty much the same ok any questions
about that yes what kind of object is w
so well I was intending you know you can
think of W as just another variable
that's given as a function of XY and Z
for example so you have a function of
XYZ defined by this formula and I call
it W I call its value W so that when I
can substitute T instead of XYZ so W is
well let's think of W as a function of
three variables okay and then when I
plug in the dependents of these three
variables on T then it becomes just a
function of T
I mean really my W here is pretty much
what I called F before there's no you
know there's no major difference between
the two okay any other questions okay
so let's see here's an application of
what we've seen so let's say that you
want to understand actually all these
rules about taking derivatives in single
variable calculus so what I showed you
at the beginning and then erased
basically justifies how to take the
derivative of the reciprocal function
and for that you didn't need
multivariable calculus but let's try to
justify the product hold for example for
the derivative so an application of this
actually is to justify the product and
quotient rules so let's think for
example of a function of two variables U
and V that's just the product u V and
let's say that U and V are actually
functions of one variable T then well D
by DT DF DT so let's say D of U V over
DT is given by the chain rule applied to
F this is DF DT so DF DT should be
absolu GU DT plus F sub V times DV DT
all right but now what is the partial of
f with respect to u its V so that's V D
u DT and partial of F with respect to V
is going to be just you
so you get back the usual product rule
okay that's a slightly complicated way
of deriving it but that's a valid way of
understanding how to take the derivative
of a product by thinking of the product
first as a function of two variables
which are U and V and then saying oh but
u and V will actually functions of a
variable T and then you do the
differentiation in two stages using the
chain rule okay similarly you can do the
quotient rule two ls do it just for
practice so if i give you the function g
equals u over V so right now I'm
thinking of it as a function of two
variables U and V but U and V themselves
are actually going to be functions of T
then well DG DT is going to be powerful
cheaper for you how much is that
how much is partial cheaper for you 1
over V times D u DT plus well next we
need to have partial G over partial V
well what's the derivative of this with
respect to V well here we need to know
how to differentiate the inverse it's
minus u over V squared times DV DT okay
and that's actually the usual quotient
whole just written in a slightly
different way
I mean just in case you really want to
see it if you clear denominators to put
the V squared then you will see
basically V well u prime times V minus V
prime times u okay
okay now let's go to something even more
select even more crazy I claim we can do
chain rules with more variables so let's
say that I have a quantity let's call it
W today for now so let's say I have 20 W
as a function of say two variables x and
y and so in the previous set up x and y
depended on some parameter t but
actually let's now look at the case
where x and y themselves are functions
of several variables let's say of two
more variables let's call them U and V
okay so I'm going to stay with these
abstract letters but you know if it
bothers you if it sounds completely
unmotivated think think about it maybe
in terms of something you might know say
polar coordinates let's say that I have
a function but defined in terms of the
polar coordinate variables R and theta
and then I know actually I want to
switch to usual coordinates x and y or
the other way around I have a function
of x and y and I want to express it in
terms of the polar coordinates R and
theta then I would like to know maybe
how the derivatives with respect to the
various sets of variables are related to
each other
okay so one way I could do it is of
course to say well now if I plug the
formula for X and the formula for Y into
formula for F then W becomes a function
of U and V and I can try to take its
partial derivatives if I have explicit
formulas well that could work but maybe
the formulas are complicated typically
if I switch you know between rectangular
and polar coordinates there might be
inverse trig there might be maybe
arctangent to express the polar angle in
terms of x and y and when I don't really
want to actually substitute arctangent
everywhere maybe I'd rather deal with
derivatives so how do I do that so the
question is what are partial W over
partial U and partial W over partial V
in terms of so let's see what do we need
to know in order to understand that well
probably we should know how W depends on
x and y if we don't know that then we're
probably toast okay so the W partial X
partial W partial Y should be required
what else should we know
what it would probably help to know how
X&Y depend on U and V if we don't know
that when we don't really know how to do
it either so we need also well u sub X
side paper around X sub u X V Y sub u y
sub V so we have a lot of partials in
there well so let's see how we can do
that
so let's start by writing DW so we know
that DW is partial F well I don't know
why I have two names W and F I mean W
and F are really the same thing here but
let's say F sub X DX plus F sub y dy
okay so far that's our new friend the
differential now what do we want to do
with it well we'd like to get rid of DX
and dy because we'd like to express
things in terms of you know the question
we are asking ourselves is let's say
that I change you a little bit how does
W change so of course what will happen
is if I change you a little bit then x
and y will change how do we change where
that's given to me by the differential
alright so DX is going to be well I can
use the differential again you know DX
well X is a function of U and V that
will be X sub u times D u plus X sub V
times DV that's again taking the
differential of a function of two
variables does that make sense then we
have the other guy f sub y times what is
dy well similarly dy is y sub u du u
plus y sub V give it
and now we have a relation between DW
and D u and DV we are expressing how W
reacts to changes in U and V which was
our goal now let's actually collect the
terms so that we see it a bit better so
that's going to be f sub x times X sub u
plus F sub y times y sub u D u plus F
sub X X sub V plus F sub y Y sub D D and
so now we have DW equals something vu
plus something DV well that coefficient
here has to be partial F partial U what
else could it be
right that's the rate of change of W
with respect to U if I forget what
happens when I change V that's the
definition of a partial similarly this
one has to be partial F over partial V
that because it's the rate of change
with respect to V if I keep u constant
so that these guys are completely
ignored so now you see how the total
differential accounts for somehow all
the partial derivatives that come as
coefficients of the individual variables
in these expressions okay so let me
maybe rewrite these formulas in a more
visible way and when we explain them to
you
okay so here's the chain rule for this
situation with two intermediate
variables and two variables that you
express these in terms of so in our
setting we get partial F over partial u
equals partial F over partial X partial
x over partial u plus partial F over
partial Y times partial Y over partial Y
and the other one same thing with V
instead of U partial F partial x times
partial X partial V plus partial F
partial Y partial Y partial V so I have
to explain various things about these
formulas because they look complicated
and actually they are not that
complicated
so a couple of things to know the first
thing so how do we remember a formula
like that well that's easy we have we
want to know how f depends on you well
what does F depend on actually it
depends on X and y so we'll put partial
F partial X and partial F partial Y now
x and y y over here well we are here
because they actually depend on you as
well
how does X depend on you well the answer
is partial X partial u how does Y depend
on U the answer is partial well by
partial Y partial u so see the structure
of these formulas is simple to find the
partial of F with respect to some new
variable you use the partials with
respect to the variables that F was
initially defined in terms of X and Y
and you multiply them by the partials of
x and y in terms of the new variable
that you want to look at v here and you
sum these things together okay so that's
the structure of a formula why does it
work well let me explain it to you in a
slightly different language
so this asks us how does F change if I
change you a little bit okay well why
would a change if you change is a little
bit where it would change because F
actually depends on x and y and the x
and y depend on you if I change you how
quickly does X Change well the answer is
partial X partial U and now if I change
X at this rate how does that cause F to
change well the answer is partial F
partial x times this guy well at the
same time Y is also changing how fast is
Y changing if I change u well at the
rate of partial Y power u but now if I
change why how does F change well the
rate of change is partial F partial Y so
the product is the effect of you know
how you change is changing Y and
therefore changing F now what happens in
the real life if I change u a little bit
well both x and y change at the same
time so how does F change well it's the
sum of the two effects okay does that
make sense good
of course if F depends on more variables
when you just have you know you just
have more terms in here okay here's
another thing that may be a little bit
confusing so what is tempting well
what's tempting here would be to
simplify these formulas by you know
removing this partial X's so let's
simplify by partial X let's simplify by
partial Y we get partial F partial u
equals partial F partial u plus partial
F partial u something is not working
properly okay so why doesn't it work
well the answer is precisely because
these are partial derivatives these are
not total derivatives and so you cannot
simplify them in that way I mean and
that's actually the reason why we use
this curly D rather when straight it's
to remind us beware there's these
simplifications that we can do with
straight DS that are not legal here so
somehow when you have a partial
derivative you must resist the urge of
simplifying things
okay so no simplifications in here
that's the simplest formula you can get
okay any questions at this point nope
yes so when would you use this and what
does it describe well it's basically
when you have a function given in terms
of a certain set of variables because
maybe there's a simple expression in
terms of those variables but ultimately
what you care about is not those
variables x and y but another set of
variables here u and v so x and y are
giving you you know a nice formula for f
but actually the relevant variables for
your problem are u and v and you know
how x and y ability to U and V so of
course what you could do is you could
plug the formulas you know the way that
we did substituting but maybe that will
give you very complicated expressions
and maybe it's actually easier to just
work with the derivatives so the
important claim here is basically we
don't need to know the actual formulas
or we need to know is the rates of
changes if we know all these rates of
change then we know how to take these
derivatives without actually having to
plug in values yes
yes you could certainly do the same
things in terms of tea if you know if x
and y we're functions of tea instead of
being functions of U and V then it would
be the same thing and you'd have the
same formulas that I had well over where
I still have it so why does that one
have straight these well the answer is I
could put curly DS if I wanted but I end
up with a function of a single variable
so if you have a single variable then
the partial with respect to that
variable is the same thing as the usual
derivative so we don't actually need to
worry about curly in that case okay but
that one is indeed it's a special case
of this one where instead of x and y
depending on two variables U and V they
depend on a single variable T now of
course whether you call your variables
you know any name you want it doesn't
matter but so this is just a slight
generalization of that well not quite
because here I also had a Z see I mean
I'm trying to just confuse you by giving
you functions that depend on various
numbers of variables if you have a
function of 30 variables things work the
same way just they are longer and you're
going to run out of letters in the
alphabet before the end okay any other
questions nope
yes what oh yes so if you will be
themselves depend on another variable
then you would you know continue with
your chain rules maybe you would know
how to express partial X partial u in
terms using the chain rule
sorry so if so if u and V depending on
yet another variable then you could get
the derivative with respect to that
using first the chain rule to pass from
UV to that new variable and then you
would plug in these formulas for
partials of F with respect to U and V so
in fact if you have several
substitutions to do you can always
arrange to use one chain over at a time
you just have to you know do them in
sequence so that's why we don't actually
learn that but you can just do it by
repeating the process I mean probably at
that stage the easiest to not get
confused actually is to manipulate
differentials because that's probably
easier yes so currently F does not exist
that's easy
okay clearly F makes no sense by itself
it doesn't exist alone what exists only
currently F Kelly D F over curly D some
variable and then that accounts only for
the rate of change with respect to that
variable leaving the others fixed while
straight D F is somehow a total
variation of F and so it accounts for
all of the partial derivatives and their
combined effects okay any more questions
nope okay so let me just finish very
quickly by telling you again you know
one example where concretely you might
want to do this is you have a function
that you want to switch between item
Euler and polar coordinates so
you just to make things a little bit
more concrete so if you had polar
coordinates that means that you know in
the plane instead of using coordinates x
and y you will coordinate you will use
coordinates our distance to the origin
and theta the angle from the x axis so
the change of variables for that is x
equals R cosine theta and y equals R
sine theta and so that means well if you
have a function f that depends on x and
y then in fact you can plug these and
get a function of R and theta and then
you can ask yourself well what is
partial f partial R and that's going to
be well you want to take partial F
partial X partial X partial R plus
partial F partial Y partial Y partial R
and so that will end up being actually f
sub x times cosine theta plus F sub y
times sine theta and you can do the same
thing to find partial F partial theta so
you can express derivatives either in
terms of X Y or in terms of our and
theta with simple relations between them
and V oh yes and one last thing I should
say so on Thursday we'll learn about
more tricks we can play with variations
of functions and one that's important
because you need to know it a tree to do
the p-set is the gradient vector so the
gradient vector it's simply a vector so
you use this downward pointing triangle
is the notation for the gradient it's
simply a vector whose components are the
partial derivatives of the function okay
so it's I mean in a way you can think of
a differential as a way to package
derivatives together into some weird
object
well the gradient is also a way to
package partials together so we'll see
on Thursday what it's good for but some
of the problems on the pset use it so